poutine le retour de l'ours dans la
danse un film signé frédéric tonolli qui
décrit bien comment vladimir poutine a
construit pas à pas sa stratégie
géopolitique un documentaire qui
interroge aussi le comportement des
occidentaux place au débat donc avec nos
invités sur ce plateau mickaël vallet
bienvenus vous êtes sénateur socialiste
de la charente-maritime membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères des
plans matin de profession elle à vidal
bienvenue à vous également vous êtes
rédactrice en chef en langue russe pour
rfi radio france international et
spécialiste des sociétés post soviétique
clémentine fauconnet est également avec
nous bien venu vous êtes maîtresse de
conférences en sciences politiques à
l'université de haute alsace est
rattaché au laboratoire sage vous est
également l'auteur de entre le marteau
et l'enclume la fabrication d'une
hégémonie partisane dans la russie de
poutine paru chez septentrion presses
universitaires christian makarian enfin
est également avec nous bien venu vous
êtes journaliste essayiste et
chroniqueur internationale au point et
vous êtes l'auteur de ce livre
généalogie de la catastrophe retrouver
la sagesse face à l'imprévisible aux
éditions du cerf merci à tous les quatre
alors parmi les premières questions que
pose ce film et outre la responsabilité
écrasante de poutine il y a le
comportement occidental avant nous était
sourd aveugle naïf mickaël vallet est ce
qu'on petit n'avait envoyé des signaux
très visible sur sa volonté d'expansion
et notamment vers l'ukraine passe une
question qui est très compliqué surtout
dans une période de guerre qui pousse un
petit peu au manichéisme moi l'image que
je prendrais c'est celle d'un à dire
d'un animal blessé ou agacé qui qui
s'énerve qui aboie qui a tenu sur un
poteau et au bout d'un an la laisse
lâche ce qui s'est passé là donc c'est
bien le chien qui est responsable de la
tacc qu'il fait mais la question c'est
de savoir jusqu'à quel point est-ce
qu'on est ce qu'il ya pas une
responsabilité dans le fait de l'avoir
excité ce qu'ils avaient besoin d'en
rajouter
moi j'ai été très étonné dans le
documentaire va étonner j'ai relevé en
tout cas le fait que le rédacteur en
chef de novaïa gazeta valide lui même la
thèse selon laquelle une promesse avait
été faite alors que c'est quand même une
personne qui est très critiquée qui est
pas suspecte de comment dire de propos
poussines et vous avez par ailleurs
choix que c'est dans le figaro le mois
dernier qui avait eu à voyez de fond
très long sur le sujet qui était très
très bien qui montré que formellement ça
semble difficile de dire vous avez eue
dans tel traité ou telle convention une
promesse qui a été rompu mais d'un autre
côté les conseillers entre eux notamment
les conseiller de clinton sur des
échanges qui a eu qui ont été
déclassifiés montre bien qu'il ya une
question d'interprétation des deux côtés
et qu en fait pour résumer il n'était
pas interdit prendre en compte dans la
façon d'aborder poutine les déclarations
à partir de 2007
qui circulent ces derniers mois avant de
parler de cette arrogance dont parle
hubert védrine qu'on entendra dans un
instant est ce que les occidentaux ont
vraiment manqué de clairvoyance et ce
qu'ils ont été naïfs est-ce qu'ils ont
été menées dans le déni moi ya deux
choses est ce qu'ils ont été la question
de la guerre est ce qu on a été naïf est
dans le déni vis-à-vis de la guerre je
pense pas je pense vraiment que le cadre
d'interprétation qui était le nôtre
c'est-à-dire une intégration poussée de
la russie dans un système international
créera une interdépendance qui diminuera
le risque d'agression était un bon cadre
ça la question de la guerre pour ce qui
est de la question des relations et de
la nature des relations à développer
avec la russie je pense pas qu'il
s'agisse de naïveté je pense qu'il
s'agit encore une fois aussi d' approche
idéologique et ou politique il ya un
courant réaliste qui est qui demande à
ce qu'on tienne compte aussi des
impératifs des états de leurs différents
intérêts qui s'appuient souvent sur la
doctrine monroe qui va nous citer la
crise des missiles à cuba pour expliquer
les difficultés russe dans la lettre où
il fera globalement c'est d'abord les
etats-unis considèrent que le continent
les continents américains sont leurs
zones naturelles d'influencé qu'il n'est
pas question de tolérer des
interventions extérieures donc pendant
la guerre froide l'union soviétique
déploie des missiles à cuba les états
unis la prenne on a une très belle crise
qui se résout l'a dit fier là la
différence est quand même très
importante dans le cas ils craignent un
parce que même si on peut comprendre que
la poussée otanienne et européenne en
direction d'êta qui furent membres de
l'union soviétique et qui ne le sont
plus depuis près de trente ans quand
même hein il ya du temps qui s'écoule et
la guerre à laquelle on assiste
actuellement n'est pas du tout provoqué
par l'ucl à l'ukraine en rien n'y a pas
de traité d'association immédiat alors
qu'il ya eu des moments de cet ordre par
avion s'y piquer des crises est-ce qu'on
a excité la bête quand il faut cogner ce
qu'on peut
non pas crier haro sur les occidentaux
mais prendre part à cette responsabilité
dans cette ce conflit alors avant de
répondre sur la question de
l'acceptation de la bête je vais j'ai
pensé aussi sur la question de
l'éventuelle surdité ou pas qu'aux
théories occidental ce qui s'est passé
ce qui a été dit dans le documentaire
tout de façon assez juste c'est le
tournant qu'a été le forum de sur la
sécurité à munich en 2007 où poutine a
dit les choses de façon très claire je
pense que s'il ya une chose qu'on peut
pas reprocher à petit c'est d'être très
clair quand même voilà et l'alliage
choses il les a presque annonce il a dit
il a dit les choses il les a annoncé ça
a été énormément le relayer c'est à dire
que lui il est en faveur d'un monde
multipolaire il est contre lui ni
polarité skis ce qu'il perçoit comme
étant militaire unilatéralisme américain
à l'impérialisme américain et contre ça
à son tour poutine et puis tous les
réseaux aussi qui sont autour un des
réseaux conservateurs des réseaux
réaliste si en termes de relations
internationales ont théorisé depuis 2007
jusqu'à aujourd'hui de façon tout à fait
ouverte et accessible des théories on
pourrait dire néo impériale qui vise à
comprendre comment faire rayonner alors
soit la russie dans son étranger proche
soit dans ce qu'on appelle le monde
russe qui l'a s'étant beaucoup plus
parce que ça touche aussi la diaspora
qui sont jusque dans les pays
occidentaux mais finalement ce projet
d'expansion d'une influence russe contre
ce qui est perçu comme étant attendu ni
paul hertz avait été tout à fait tout à
fait annoncé et sans doute pas
suffisamment entendus et pris au sérieux
on a été je pense très très beau être
très surpris de ce qui s'est passé à
partir du 24 février au matin dans son
ampleur mais sinon tu rétrospectivement
on peut dire qu'il y avait quand même
beaucoup d'éléments qui avait en tout
cas très bien montré dans le
documentaire ça voilà évident voilà mais
du coup mais sinon en plus
l'accélération phénoménal depuis je
dirais le tournante de 2012 au moment où
poutine est revenu aux affaires il ya eu
en plus en terme de politique intérieure
ce qu'est ce que je connais le mieux un
tournant aussi très anti occidental 13
antilles avec la crainte est une
révolution qu'ils soient organisés en
russie contre poutine la mise en avant
des valeurs conservatrices et qui
vraiment viser aussi d'un point de vue
géopolitique à construire vraiment une
opposition entre un occident qui avait
perdu les valeurs traditionnelles et une
russie qui était gardienne des valeurs
traditionnelles et qui pouvait aussi
éventuellement les défendre un petit peu
partout dans le monde et plus encore que
la naïveté ou de la surdité je vais vous
donner la parole dans un instant
christian mas careiron c'est que
peut-être les occidentaux auraient été
arrogant même à certains moments de
l'histoire avec la russie et ça c'est
hubert védrine qui le dit très
franchement dans le cinéma une période
le quelques années où les occidentaux
ont fait preuve du bri d'arrogance de
triomphalisme ils ont vraiment cru
qu'après la fin de lurs la russie était
devenue une puissance secondaire qui ne
comptait pas dont on n'aurait pas se
préoccuper et qu'elle est devenue un
pays bas le plus ou moins normalisée
mais qui disparaissaient du champ de la
vraie grande politique alors là
christian makarian c'est vraiment haro
sur les occidentaux alors je crois que
monsieur védrine a raison de parler d'
arrogance mais il faut à mon avis
revenir au point de départ le point de
départ c'est tout de même une promesse
verbale fait amerrir gorbatchev au
moment des événements de berlin
ce qui est donc très vague qui donne
lieu à aucun papier aucun document écrit
ce qui va être reproché à gorbatchev et
là l'opposition et la détestation que
vladimir poutine plus tard va nourrir
pour gorbatchev qu'il estime comme le
coupable idéal de la chute de l'union
soviétique de tous les systèmes numéro
général va accentuer cela mais en vérité
on peut pas faire un raccourci trop
rapide en voyant racontons avant oui je
suis contre la culpabilisation de
l'occident ça suffit ça ne produit que
des résultats désastreux
culpabiliser et nous auto flageller
c'est quelque chose qui produit la
destruction des valeurs que nous portons
et les valeurs ou que nous portons sont
la démocratie les droits de l'homme la
personne humaine la liberté d'aller
l'intention t'offre l'âge explique l
histoire
gardons que ce qu'il y a de vrai dans ce
que dit hubert védrine et la fainéantise
intellectuelle dans les occidentaux ont
fait preuve nous avons cessé de
travailler sur les causes idéologiques
et sur l'approfondissement
l'enfoncement de l'idéologie en soit
intéressant cas pas encore dans le champ
historique profond et à mon avis je vous
donne une interprétation personnelle qui
vaut ce qu'elle vaut mais vladimir
poutine ne peut pas s'expliquer skis ce
que nous vivons à l'heure actuelle en
ukraine ne peuvent pas s'expliquer en le
détachant de la conception même du
pouvoir qu'a vladimir poutine c'est à
dire lié le politico militaire un
pouvoir qui a besoin de guerre et que
pour produire ces guerres pour légitimer
sa durée n'oubliez pas qu'il a fait des
réformes constitutionnelles à répétition
de manière à pouvoir rester au pouvoir
jusqu'en
2036 et pour rester vous achetez en 2030
si ça se fait pas en claquant des doigts
il faut des guerres et des guerres
régulière poutine fait la guerre pour
justifier le fait qu'il reste au pouvoir
de façon longue même plus loin il l'a
dit lui-même que pierre le grand et que
ivan le terrible et ça on découvre
aujourd'hui abidal non je pense pour
l'analyser avant pouvait pas le voir
venir
c'est très difficile à dire en fait ce
que ce que je reconnais - comme comme
grande qualité ce documentaire quand
bien même je suis en désaccord avec de
nombreux points et je pense qu'il
faudrait rentrer dans des détails parce
qu'il ya toujours des approximations et
que tout est dans le détail mais ce que
ça rend perceptible et c'est quelque
chose qu'il est très difficile de
s'imaginer je pense en tant
qu'occidental quand on n'a pas vécu en
russie quand on n'a pas vécu pendant ces
années là c'est que moi j'étais
étudiante en russie comme plein d'autres
j'ai vécu dans les années 90
régulièrement la russie pour la grande
majorité de la population russe et
soviétique
ça n'a pas été une libération la
disparition de l'union soviétique
c'était un effondrement avec un état
failli avec le chaos qui s'ensuit
personne ne peut regretter ça
concrètement ça a été absolument
dramatique donc évidemment qu'il y a en
plus le sentiment de la puissance perdue
et puis dans les imaginaires il ya
effectivement des tas de on va dire d'un
bâtard de la russie et de l'union
soviétique des relations du pouvoir
continue même suivi par son peuple plus
ou moins mais après il travaille
l'idéologie il n'agit pas dans un espace
transparent mais je pense que clémentine
fauconnier connais mieux la production
idéologique interne en russie en tout
cas en expérience pour avoir été en tant
que française en russie
peu de temps avant en union soviétique
évidemment que se promener dans ce pays
c'était se dire mon dieu mais qu'est ce
qui est en train de se passer que vivent
ces gens qui vous arrêter même dans la
rue qu'on faisait la queue avec eux pour
vous dire et pourquoi vous êtes là on
veut tous partir pourquoi vous venez et
c'est fait mais l'expérience ici on va
encore quelques instants mickaël vallet
sur les occidentaux quand on parle des
occidentaux on parle de qui on parle
surtout des états unis comme cherchent à
le elle expliqué les demis routine une
excellente question est ce que les
ombres sont un peu pris en otage aussi
entre ces deux blocs qui signerait tout
à fait c'est une très bonne question
parce que dans les occidentaux d'abord
j'aime pas dire les occidentaux d'un
côté la russie l'eau parce que la russie
fait aussi partie de l'occident va pas
rentrer dans les détails mais peut
parler de l'union européenne des
organisations politiques militaires et
des états unis je crois qu'il faut
distinguer l'union européenne d'un côté
certains pays qui ont une proximité
historique et on l'a vu dans la façon
dont le président macron a essayé de
gérer en tout cas une partie de la crise
dans des rapports qu'on peut avoir un
peu plus étroits entre certains pays et
la russie l'otan et les états unis parce
que de se dire il faut pas qu'on se
flagellent nous les occidentaux pour
reprendre le terme là dessus c'est pas
c'est pas interdit de comprendre aussi
que par exemple je crois au mois de juin
l'année qui a précédé le mois de juin
qui a précédé le la guerre et
l'agression quand vous avez des états
unis qui en remettent une couche sur le
fait de dire nous soutiendrons quoi
qu'il arrive une demande d'intégration
de l'ukraine dans l'otan ils savent très
bien ce qu'ils font quand l'allemagne se
annonce qu'elle se réarment elle va pas
le faire avec des équipements européens
donc ils savent très bien ce qu'ils font
quand ils poussent les feux de l'otan
ils savent ce qu'ils font aussi donc je
pense qu'il faut distinguer non pas pour
introduire des recommandations en
tension mais si on si on peut se
reprocher parfois à tort ou à raison
d'avoir été naïve sur les comportements
de la russie et ses faux pas l'être et
que les états unis parce que des régimes
qui ont besoin de guerre parfois pour
justifier des prises de position ou qui
ont des dynasties où on a un président
qui voit son fils succéder à son
successeur ça existe aux états unis à la
merci du compte ce que je voudrais dire
là dessus c'est que pour essayer
d'introduire et bien évidemment pas avec
les mêmes valeurs pourquoi oui mais je
pense qu'il faut se garder d'une d'une
forme de d'occidental au centrisme ou ne
pas être être nos centres et et le film
de bloc occidental harmonieux vie de
décider de se décentrer un peu pour
comprendre non pas pour excuser mais
pour comprendre quelles vont être les
motivations d'un peuple ou d'une
politique étrangère dont on sait je suis
toujours ce ver de lermontov qui dit
littéralement la russie est imprévisible
bon alors c'est facile de donner des
explications faciles mais là pour le
coup le 24 février on n'est pas trop
prévu la ligne qui serait qu'ils
seraient franchis mais il faut essayer
de comprendre un peu moi je comprends
tout à fait ce que dit madame quand vous
quand vous voyez ce que c'est que le 9
mai en russie quand vous voyez
l'importance attachée pour des raisons
qui sont nourris dans l'idéologie aussi
mais à la grande guerre patriotique et
au reste on peut pas tout à fait
s'étonner par exemple des taux de
popularité qu'on voit chez poutine en ce
moment et ce y aurait même eu un petit
jeu dangereux joué notamment par les
américains au moment de la révolution de
maidan je ne sais pas quelle honte il
faut cogner est-ce que effectivement on
a joué un petit jeu dangereux et on a
excité la bête aussi en essayant
d'attaquer de l'intérieur l'ukraine et
ont prononcé valeurs démocratiques qui
hérisse est le poil de vladimir poutine
alors un jeu dangereux ou un jeu
peut-être pas tout à fait mesurer mes
jeux qui remonte à mon sens bien avant
bien avant mada celle qui commence avec
son app et les révolutions de couleur
ont commencé de 2003 en géorgie et puis
la fameuse révolution orange en ukraine
qui a été du point de vue de la
politique intérieure russes un tournant
majeur voilà c'est à dire qu'il y avait
déjà eu ça a été dit je me suis en plus
il s'est rappelé dans le documentaire
via une mini lune de miel très relative
lorsque vladimir poutine est arrivé au
pouvoir où il a tenté il a quand même
envoyé des perches pour tenter de
coopérer voilà notamment toute la
question de l'antiterrorisme même si
c'était aussi tout à fait intéressé côté
poutine parce qu'elle est aussi la
tchétchénie évidemment mais il y avait
une volonté de jouer une espèce de jeu
et de coopérer plus ou moins à l'égalité
2003 c'est la sphère darcos qui a été
reçu à l'ouest pour le dire rapidement
m'excuserez mais notamment par les états
unis comme étant vraiment
le témoignage de l'autoritarisme
poutinien et sa reprise en main à la
fois sur la politique et sur l'économie
et notamment tous les secteurs
énergétiques qui sont évidemment très
important et puis ensuite suite à ça il
a commencé à y avoir donc ces fameuses
révolutions de couleurs ou des dirigeant
prorusse donc il permettait aussi la
routine garder son influence sur sa zone
sur sa zone historique on pourrait dire
voilà ont perdu les élections suite à
des protestations massives après des
élections qui ont vu l'arrivée au
pouvoir de dirigeants plutôt pro
occidentaux et ça ça a été très
clairement inter interprété par
comptines et ceux qui l'entourent
puisque poutine on dit souvent poutine
comme un acteur collectif un petit peu
et donc du coup tous les milieux aussi y
compris russie unie donc le parti sur
lequel j'ai travaillé ça a été
interprété vraiment comme une tentative
d'ingérence non seulement pour
déstabiliser géopolitiquement la russie
et la rendre plus faibles et
deuxièmement comme un espace
d'entraînement en sachant que l'année
dernière traiter qu'avec la maison était
une ou pas c'était voir une ingérence il
y avait clairement un soutien manifeste
en tout cas dans tout la façon dont ont
été reçus en faveur de ses forces parce
que c'était aussi pro démocratiques et
qu'elle se revendaient de la liberté des
élections des droits de l'homme etc et
le ca s'est répétée finalement presque
enrichi ce fameux trône en 2012 qu'est
ce qui se passe et maman vladimir
poutine revient au pouvoir ceux ci le
plus gros mouvement de protestation puis
la russie est connu depuis
l'effondrement de l'urss et qu'est-ce
qui émarge à ce moment là la figure d'
alexeï navalni pour lequel il ya eu
quand même une très grande sympathie
alors vu aussi ce qui lui est arrivé
plus tard mais pour lequel il ya eu
quand même un soutien assez important en
france par exemple et puis il y aurait
donc du coup tout ça ça nourrit d'idées
peut-être pas tout à fait à tort que il
y à une hostilité contre le régime
poutine aussi parce qu'il est
autoritaire et qui se défend d'autres
valeurs que les valeurs américaines et
européennes et que du coup il y à des
risques à la fois géopolitique 9,6 en
termes de politique intérieure jeu qu'il
joue à deux quand même un trait sur ma
carrière lorsque vous rappeler c'est la
façon dont le monde a été régie ce
monde-là aux soviétiques autour de
l'ukraine et c'est très important
pourquoi parce que l'ukraine à la fin de
l'urss et la troisième puissance
nucléaire du monde et oui par le nombre
de têtes nucléaires qu'elle héberge sur
son sol pas parce qu'elle les a
produites mais parce que dans le cadre
de l'urss elle avait reçu la mission de
stocker ses têtes nucléaires qui était
pointé sur l'europe bon
la façon dont on la dénouer cette crise
était assez remarquable dans une
coopération entre l'occident donc en
l'occurrence l'otan etats-unis et europe
et la fédération de russie on s'est mis
d'accord et on a signé les protocoles
dit de budapest en 1994 que disent ces
protocoles violée par la russie ils
disent que en échange de la
dénucléarisation complète de l'ukraine
indispensable la sécurité du monde
entier dieu merci et qu'ils aient eu
lieu eh bien les etats-unis le
royaume-uni et la russie puis par
adjonction tacite la france et
l'allemagne et d'autres pays aussi se
portent garants des frontières
extérieures des limites frontalière de
l'ukraine la russie a signé ce document
donc il faut savoir ce qu'elle veut le
fait que monsieur poutine arrivant au
pouvoir à la fin de l'année 1999 cinq
ans après va considérer ce document
comme totalement sans valeur accessoires
signifie quand même de la part du
pouvoir russe un engagement dans une
voie non respectueuses des accords
internationaux dans une voie de non de
refus du concert internationale qui est
extrêmement significative alors après
que l'occident ait commis des erreurs
notamment barack obama en traitant la
russie de puissance secondaire de
puissance régionale que des phrases
comme le fameux sénateurs qui présidait
la commission de la défense au sénat
effet du effet mal cette phrase étant la
suivante la russie n'est plus qu'une
station-service équipés de fusils
nucléaire oui c'est blessant on a
humilié la russie et jacques chirac s'en
émouvait et hubert védrine sont
inquiétés il avait raison on a eu midi
et la russie mais c'était dans un temps
t + 2 dans un temps t ou même t + 1 nous
avons proposé avant on peut pas faire fi
de l'accord otan russie qui a été signé
à la fin des années 90 est renouvelé il
ya un conseil il existe j'aime bien le
leur a bien un conseil otan russie qui
existe toujours pourquoi est-ce que la
russie ne veut pas jouer ce rôle là
parce qu'elle a choisi un autre cheval
qui est celui de ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure clémentine rousse qui mirent
le monde russes la sphère d'influencé
la possible responsabilité occidental
dans cet impérialisme poutinien doit
évidemment pas faire oublier aussi la
gigantesque ambitions et peut-être même
l'obsession de la dîmière poutine qui
serait de faire renaître cette grande
russie de faire revivre cet empire russe
elle a aussi plusieurs intervenants dans
le film mais disent écoutez
fondamentalement ça s'inscrit dans ce
grand projet dans son grand dessein
poutine se voit comme le rassembleur
d'été russe et il est certainement animé
par une haute conscience historique il
entend passer à la postérité
il entend passer pour un nouveau pierre
legrand alors je crois que tout le monde
est assez d'accord sur cette idée que
vladimir poutine serait vrai en grand
empereur mais est ce que cette fois sur
le cac et craignent un ils se cassent
les dents est ce que vous sentez qu'il
est tombé sur un os à la fois parce que
l'ukraine résistent beaucoup plus qu'ils
ne l'imaginaient est à la fois parce que
les occidentaux se semble aussi résister
beaucoup d'obstacles et de réaction qui
n'avaient pas été anticipées on peut le
voir comme ça on peut voir que d'une
part les plans qui avait été préparé par
l'entourage qui devrait devenir poutine
et qui n'osent généralement pas
s'opposer à ces agents ou les éclairer
de manière critique les plans ont échoué
ce pas d'ailleurs le premier échec
puisque le fsb avait déjà échoué à
contenir maidan et avait été d'ailleurs
plus tôt
plutôt puni pour ça puisque c'est
ensuite la défense qui s'est chargé de
l'annexion de la crim est donc grave
erreur de stratégie l' erreur de
stratégie grave seul développement des
événements le feu le drapeau lui
évidemment oui mickaël vallet il ya des
choses qui au bout d'un moment chappat
l'analyse la plus immédiate la question
de la conscience nationale et du
sentiment patriotique ce sont des
éléments qui se crée parfois des moments
vous ne les attendait pas sont des
réactions vous attendiez pour plus
tarder avec des comment dire des
éléments vous ne pensiez pas aussi aussi
fort le fait d'être russophone le fait
d'avoir en partage même si c'est
extrêmement compliqué par rapport aux
différentes églises sont des églises
nation aux siens en ukraine même si vous
passez vous et en partagent une culture
orthodoxe même si vous avez le fait que
la crimée finalement depuis le temps que
les russes ont désaccord ils sont là ils
sont là bas non ça n'a pas été aussi
simple et cette espèce de précipitée qui
s'est cristallisée sur le sentiment
patriotique ukrainien et le fait d'avoir
fait front comme ça a probablement été
l'élément que les russes en tout cas que
le pouvoir russe n'a pas pris en compte
et il est possible aussi que nous
n'ayons pas penser que l'ukraine
résisterez comme elle résiste du fait de
ce sentiment patriotique là et ça ce
sont des choses qui sont très longues
analyses et ce n'est pas aussi simple de
le penser moi je vous dis il ya pas mal
de personnes dont je fais partie qui
était persuadé que une ligne rouge mais
même même pas la première celle là et
c'était évident faire couler du sang de
civils russophone blanc orthodoxe
c'était pas possible c'était un
contresens ça a été ça a été franchi
quand même été quelques-uns être étonné
ce qui prouve bien que l'idéologie qui
anime la niña poutine et les hommes du
crooner autour de lui est plus forte que
tout sentiment fraternel puisque ce qui
doit l'emporter
c'est la notion de pouvoir et n'ont pas
la notion de civilisation et la façon
dont cet habillé y compris par le
patriarche de russie kirill est
totalement artificielle
en vérité ça consiste à tuer et et là
c'est absolument catastrophique et je
terminerai juste un mot sur sur
l'ukraine l'ukraine a démontré qu'elle
était une grande a sion parce que tout
simplement elle avait été empêché à
plusieurs reprises y compris pendant la
seconde guerre entre mm d'être d'exister
et de s'exprimer et il ya des nations
comme ça la nation polonaise qui a été
trois fois partagé trois fois rayé de la
carte qui existent et qui prouve bel et
bien qu'elles le sont puissantes et
enracinée c'est d'autant plus fort que
le peuple ukrainien et divers mais il
est uni et la leçon elle est punie par
quoi par l'esprit démocratique et si ça
ça n'est pas une leçon du début du
xxième siècle alors il faut renoncer à
tous donc puisque le sujet du débat
rebecca c'est nous européens sommes nous
allés trop loin en avant nous manquer à
la russie quelque part eh bien je crois
qu'il faut répondre euh on a une
occasion peut-être ici de se réhabiliter
en restaurant les valeurs les valeurs
fondamentales qui sont celles de
l'occident sont réclamées aussi pas le
peuple ukrainien ça n'est pas rien elle
à vis d'elle et clémentine un très
brièvement là les deux points sur lequel
je voulais insister effectivement on a
été beaucoup parmi les observateurs
régulier de l'espace post soviétique et
de la russie être surpris par l'entrée
en guerre par une guerre en bonne et due
forme parce qu'effectivement ça ne
semblait pas compatible avec les
objectifs rationnelle politique
escomptée pour la russie la deuxième
chose c'est que tout à l'heure vous
parliez de la nécessité pour nous de
nous de faire un pas de côté la capacité
à penser en dehors de son espace
ethniques mais de toute évidence des
leaders libéraux tels que vladimir
poutine et erdogan est aussi les chinois
ont fait le choix de promouvoir d'autres
récits nationaux et d'autres récits de
puissance politique ils font des
alliances tactiques et ils viennent ou
challenge est quand même sur les
questions démocratiques ils le font en
faisant en s'appuyant sur un fond
culturel en ravivant en fait des
idéologies locale mais fatalement je
pense que malgré tout ils deviennent ils
viennent nous concurrencer sur le
terrain de la démocratie et c'est aussi
parce qu'ils en ont peur parce qu'ils
ont trop bas
ces valeurs des n'a pas de pouvoir
est-ce que là ça pourrait provoquer la
chute de blé d'hiver poutine alors c'est
la question ce qu'on se pose évidemment
pour l'instant ça n'a pas vraiment l'air
d'être le chemin qui suivent il ne
fragilise pas même pas de l'intérieur il
faudra voir il faudra pas rater il
faudra voir les faits à terme d des
sanctions économiques aussi les effets
sur son entourage mais je voulais
rebondir aussi sur la citation tout à
l'heure tout d'abord sur pierre le grand
la comparaison poutine pierre legrand
alors c'est normal de vouloir faire des
comparaisons historiques food inc pierre
le grand et petit staline je pense que
c'est pas tout à fait juste parce que
poutine contrairement à pierre le grand
et staline sans vouloir jeter des fleurs
à ceux de dirigeants
violent et sanguinaire avait des grandes
ambitions alors avec un coup il m'a très
très important mais des ambitions de
changement de la russie 2 de mener un
changement social économique politique
géopolitique c'est pas de poutine n'a
pas du tout cette envergure il n'a
jamais prétendu l'avoir et personne dans
son entourage ne prétend que le
poutinisme a été un moment de
modernisation c'est un moment à la
limite de restauration de tentatives de
restauration et encore qui sera jamais
de faire ce que la de faire de la russie
ce qui a été lu et donc mais on n'est
pas du tout dans les mêmes dans les
mêmes dimensions et lui-même dans les
même volonté est d'ailleurs en russie ni
quand il s'agissait de s'inspirer de
différentes périodes de l'histoire russe
dont vladimir poutine se pourrait se
réclame et c'était plutôt alexandre iii
qui n'a pas réellement passé une très
très grande postérité donc à une plus
grande je dirais entre guillemets
modestie ce qui n'empêche pas qu'ils
aient voilà le violon que jérémy pas
d'unanimité sur cette question la
deuxième chose sur la question de savoir
où on va on va bien voir ce que devient
la russie et le système poutine dans les
mois les années qui viennent mais pour
l'instant je voulais un tout petit peu
relativisé l'idée de l'échec sur le
court terme puisque le système poutine
dont il a changé la constitution pour
pouvoir se maintenir jusqu'en 2036 mais
il est quand même extrêmement sclérosé
de l'intérieur il c'est légitime et
pendant une période grâce à la hausse du
pib ce qui peut plus faire aujourd'hui
le système est complètement bloquée n'y
a plus du tout de perspectives de
changement de modernisation l'heure n'a
pas encore parlé jean n'aura pas le
temps sans doute de parler de ladislav
sourkov qui a été un grands conseillers
pendant 2012 et qu'il y avait quelques
ambitions même que tous d'essayer de
construire je dirais une forme
d'autoritarisme 2.0 qui permet aussi à
la russie de s'insérer dans l'économie
globale et ce à tous toutes ces
ambitions là ils ont complètement
disparu la sq a réussi entre guillemets
poutine même si un coût humain très
important s'est occupé l'agenda
médiatique mondiale et continuer à
contrôler le pays pour combien de temps
on verra mais la question du coût humain
en russie elle se pose pas du tout de la
même façon dans les démocraties c'est ça
qu'on oublie toujours qu'il ya des
attentes et des prises d'otages en
russie il ya énormément de morts et
c'est pas suffisant pour fragiliser
l'état voilà et gens que ça je pense que
c'est un des grands causses du
malentendu est ouest je reprends la main
il nous reste quelques minutes j'aurais
aussi qu'on revienne sur les ambitions
de la demie à poutine qui ne semble pas
s'arrêter à l'europe de l'est et s'est
aussi montrée dans le documentaire
gardons que ces quelques minutes pour en
parler il veut s'étendre on parle du
moyen-orient du proche orient mais aussi
de l'afrique l'ours a trouvé son pot de
miel nous dit le réalisateur du
documentaire et il a semble-t-il
quelques atouts de séduction écouter la
russie dit bah voila moi j'arrive chez
toi je vais pas tomber pas de faire des
leçons de démocratie
j'assure ta sécurité je vais faire on te
vas très critiqué mais je vais faire
comme faisait les français je vais
mettre un conseiller en sécurité auprès
de auprès de ta présidence et on va
pouvoir comme s'assurer non seulement tu
as écrit sécurité mais je vais aussi
aller dans ton armée faire la formation
dans les forces armées centrafricaines
d'une façon tout à fait officielle et ce
sera évidemment le dernier thème de ce
débat gardant quelques minutes christian
m'a carrément est ce que la méthode
russe séduit en afrique alors pour
l'instant elle profite du déclin
français entre guillemets les échecs
constatés au mali
permettent à certains groupes russes de
nourrir certaines ambitions mais on l'a
vu avec quelle maladresse on a vu la
semaine dernière la manipulation
grossière et scandaleuse avec laquelle
on a essayé de
fabriquer de toutes pièces un charnier
les forces de deux du groupe wagner ou
en accuser les français heureusement par
des images diffusées par les services
français on l'a vu que les russes
enterré décor qui savait qu'ils étaient
allés chercher en attendant l'image des
français oui il va d'aujourd'hui les
énergies à plusieurs puissances qui
fonce à la turquie fait exactement la
même chose en faisant des percées au
maghreb et en afrique noire aussi en
afrique en afrique centrale aurait pu
sur d'africaines la turquie avancent
elles avancent aussi dans beaucoup
d'autres pays donc la france
malheureusement et ça je pense qu'on en
a pas vraiment assez conscience à paris
fait l'effet d'une proie vue parce qu'on
voit qu'un côté du miroir il faut voir
l'autre côté il ya un côté mais ça c'est
typiquement français bien que tes
affaires à saisir si vous voulez dans le
dans le retrait français mais je crois
que plus globalement ce que vise la
russie c'est reprendre pied absolument
partout où elle le peut n'oublions pas
l'amérique latine n'oubliant pas et
sarah très loin que le patriarche de
l'église russe kirill a signé un papier
avec le pack françois que le pape
françois doit bien regretter aujourd'hui
d'avoir signé ça ça oui pour pour
approcher les églises mais en vérité
c'était une reconnaissance d'un certain
pouvoir russe et je terminerai en disant
que l'ambition à c'est la conviction de
tous les penseurs américains de tous les
think tanks américains c'est que
l'ambition suprême de russes c'est de
sortir les américains d'europe et ça
expliquerait pourquoi les américains
mettent une telle âpreté à se réinvestir
à envoyer des armements et des centaines
de millions de dollars pour aider et
armés l'ukraine afin que et là je cite
le secrétaire à la défense américain
afin que les russes n'ai plus envie
jamais de tenter ce qu'ils ont voulu
faire en ukraine donc c'est assez clair
il ya une nouvelle partie américano
russes et les russes l'ont désiré ce
match là ils ont donc l'ambition
finalement peut-être un peu plus grande
que ce qu'on imaginait que demandent
s'il faut cogner chez vladimir poutine
s'il veut même aller jusqu'à ces terres
là dont on parle alors l'amérique latine
s'est pas dit dans le documentaire on
parle du proche-orient du moyen-orient
et bien sûr de l'afrique mais ça reste
aussi alors l'afrique et aussi comme des
enjeux économiques très importants c'est
aussi la course aux ressources et le
rapport alliés rivaux qui unit la chine
et la russie dit que la chine est aussi
très présente sur le continent africain
aussi pour des raisons économiques
c'est aussi une façon de continuer ce
que ça a été assez bien dit dans le
documentaire un moment c'est à dire pour
la russie d'arriver à s'imposer par sa
capacité de nuisance en fait est
d'arriver à se servir de toutes les
brèches possible par exemple la
situation de faiblesse de la france au
mali pourra pour papa revenir finalement
à acquérir une plus grande visibilité
symbolique économique politique mais qui
n'est pas direct enfin même si on sait
très bien vers où se diriger les cages
puisqu'il s'agit quand même du groupe
wagner pour l'essentiel qui est présent
en afrique est pas tout à fait
officiellement de la russie on a même
une opposition chine russie face aux
états unis tous en train de s'organiser
absolument rien de nouveau dans tout ça
c est pourquoi est-ce que la russie ne
le faisait pas avant parce que là on
n'avait pas les moyens dont il a d'abord
fallu se reconstruire pourquoi ils n'ont
pas attaqué en certains points avant
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas l'armé qu'il
fallait pour ce faire il a d'abord fallu
s'organiser poser les alors même si le
coût de poutine joueur d'échecs
besoin mais parce qu'on a besoin aussi
de schématiser tout ça simplement les
choses se font dans l'ordre au moment où
on en a la capacité et je vais le dire
de manière
avec euphémisme mais des états qui
sortent de leur zone d'influencé
immédiate pour essayer d'aller contrôler
des ressources en échange de quoi ils
tranquillise le dictateur local ils
mettent un peu ça en coupe réglée il est
possible sauf à ce que je me trompe que
la russie ne soit pas la première pour
dire très gentiment et poliment et vous
avez aujourd'hui en fait la souveraine
la géopolitique et le contrôle d'un
territoire aujourd'hui le contrôle d'un
territoire ne passe pas uniquement par
l'idée de la souveraineté en occupons
mais un fantoche point c'est pas ça
c'est le contrôle des mines ce le
contrôle des terres rares c'est le
contrôle des canaux de communication
c'est la stratégie c'est la diplomatie
ou pouvoir d'influencé vous savez quand
les chinois ont été les premiers à
reconnaître le régime taliban ils ont
été dans les premiers à recevoir des
concessions minières aussi donc tout
cela fait partie de la panne je dis pas
que c'est bien
une valeur mais c'est une question c'est
assez la panoplie classique sauf que
maintenant la russie a mis un pied
dehors et commence à s'organiser un peu
plus de ce point de vue là mais le coût
du conseiller auprès du président en
échange de quoi en tire les ressources
premières très franchement c'est pas
très très nouveau david haye pour
conclure oui moi ce que je voulais
mettre en lumière c'est que
effectivement d'abord ce n'est pas très
nouveau ensuite dans je pense là la
manière de d'implémenter c'est s'est
prise de pouvoir par les russes il ya
quand même une manière qui témoigne une
très forte asymétrie c'est quand même
une puissance faible qui se focalise sur
des points très particulier dont elle a
besoin pour son exercice pour son
économie mais qui n'est pas en capacité
d'ouvrir et de d'offrir un modèle de
gouvernance et les russes ne font pas
campagne sur leur modèle de gouvernance
ils s'en tiennent à des accords très
précises sécurité économie points
deuxième chose pour moi ce qui a été ce
qui suit la surprise qui pour moi a
constitué le début de cette guerre et le
train de sanctions qui ce qui est en
oeuvre c'est quand même pour moi je
pense pour vladimir poutine un moment où
il est il a réussi à restaurer une
capacité d'influencé de la russie sur
l'échiquier international
et désormais ils désintègre la russie de
l'ordre multilatérale il l'a replie sur
elle-même et la contrôler mieux et on
s'arrêtera là merci merci infiniment à
tous les quatre d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis comme chaque semaine avant
de vous quitter et si vous avez envie
d'approfondir le sujet je vous cite un
tout dernier ouvrage poutine l'ukraine
les faces cachées de vladimir federowski
éditions balland a très vite sur public
sénat
[Musique]